Montell Al and one set piece but no
longer
the forces of steam rally to the west as
the kingdom awakens its industrial
hunger secret wonders unfold in the East
bracing to fight for their sacred
treasures the worlds of steam and
fantasy collide
the world is a dangerous place players
joined the fight as one of twelve
distinct classes unleashing mechanized
fury and powerful sorcery in black gold
online fast paced action combat system
the world sits on the brink of war
forces rally and prepare for battle
enter heart pounding large-scale
battlegrounds on powerful beasts of war
and mechanized battle vehicles black
gold on lines customizable personal
carrier system gives players the chance
to develop over 100 distinct carriers
for battle fight for control as the east
and west collide in a struggle for the
continent
explore world filled with dark and
mysterious secrets faced monsters and
covetous enemies in the search for
treasure in chambers of greed
join in a great adventure to discover
new wonders and journey to the far
corners of the vast world team up with
friends for cooperative instances
entering amazing maps filled with perils
unknown horrible creatures and
impossible challenges oh wait guarding
incredible riches fan together to defeat
powerful bosses explore winding
labyrinths and delve into the hidden
secrets of the land dangers abound as
the adventure begins
join in the struggle for domination of
the continent in energy well battles
form armies of hundreds in bid for
control of precious resources in large
scale faction revealed wards
the powerful forces of darkness pervade
the world only the brave the cunning and
the strong shall drive Ford your
allegiances make peace or war the choice
is yours
you